hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up
the UK's chair of the UK's Net Zero
review speaks out against a new Cumbria
coal mine at the official launch of
mission zero
how atmospheric River storms batter in
California being made worse by climate
change
and why beavers are being reintroduced
in Hampshire as part of a biodiversity
transformation
[Music]
foreign
show where we track the changes to our
world and investigate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis now the author of The Independent
review of the UK's Net Zero targets has
spoken out against the Cumbria Coal Mine
during the official launch of mission
zero so Chris Skidmore said if the
recommendations had already been in
place the government wouldn't approve
the UK's first deep Coal Mine in 30
years
the honest answer is if the
recommendations in the report had been
in place if there had been Net Zero
tests that have been put in place as
part of the planning system uh if local
authorities had a statutory duty to buy
by Net Zero then that decision would not
have been able to be made
I obviously personally believe the coal
mine decision is a mistake
so let's wait and see whether this coal
mine actually happens but if this report
was taken forwards it never will
well during the launch Mr Skidmore said
the choices that made this year will
affect whether Net Zero can be achieved
echoing his warning in the report that
the UK needs to move quickly and take
advantage of opportunities presented by
decarbonisation chaitana Kumar the head
of environments and green transition of
the new economies Foundation uh joins me
now thanks so much for joining us this
afternoon
thank you thank you for having me so
first of all you would have heard there
from Chris kidmore saying practically
that the coal mining Cumbria it was a
mistake it wouldn't have happened if
this review was in place do you think
that's encouraging language as we move
forward towards the potentially opening
of this coal mine
I think it is and and the key sentence
he mentioned was wait and see what
happens with the gold mine because
um the Secretary of State might have
approved it but I think we still have a
long way to go before actually digging
the coal out of the ground in Cumbria uh
but the bigger picture of course is
really looking at the fact that we still
do not have our institutions and our
policies and our laws in line with Net
Zero uh the fact that a local Authority
for example uh on the basis of jobs on
the basis of a few other things that
might just benefit uh a few people in a
local area which is also a doubt uh you
know is Up For Debate uh can can
undermine sort of the Net Zero
legislation altogether is is up for the
bit is he is concerned so what we really
need to think about is how do we align a
lot of our institutional mechanisms
policies and laws in line with what
we've got with Net Zero and Mr Kumar one
of the more prominent aspects of the
review was talking about how Net Zero
can actually help boost the economy did
you think that was quite encouraging
it was and I'd argue that was one of the
highlights of the review uh if you
consider the background of this review
it was commissioned by the former prime
minister Liz truss and some of our
cabinet members really had a doubt
whether netsuda was a good thing or
perhaps we're going too fast on Net Zero
and that's why they commissioned this
review and the review comes out very
clear it's fairly unambiguous in stating
the biggest Economic Opportunity for
Britain in the 21st century is in
NetZero is really an inviting investment
for the low-carbon economy of the future
and it's also on sort of addressing some
of the bigger challenges the other
challenges that the government has
identified like leveling up uh the fact
that parts of the knob are left behind
in many ways Net Zero is another
opportunity another Avenue to try and
lift those regions and improve the
economy of those regions as well so I
think it's a overall a very very
positive report and it's not just the
review from one person it's not the
opinion of one person about 1800
businesses and Civil Society members
have submitted their views so it's an
overwhelming opinion of a majority of
the population here that's essentially
saying we need to go faster than that
zero because that's where the
opportunity for economy and well-being
really lie
okay try telling uh Kumar thank you very
much for your time on the daily climate
show
okay let's take a look at some other
stories making news today for you and
climate activates have occupied a giant
Digger at a coal mine in Western Germany
it's all part of that ongoing protest
against the destruction of a nearby
Village for the expansion of a separate
mine our Energy company rwe said that
four people climbed onto a digger early
this morning and operations at lignite
mine or they've been forced
more than 50 heads of state
International organizations and Business
Leaders a meeting in the Swiss Alpine
Resort of davros this week for the 2023
meeting of the world economic Forum with
discussions on the program heavily
linked to climate change now some
activists have raised concerns about
greenwashing at the summit and
campaigners including Vanessa nacarte
and Greta tunberg will travel to the
resort in the coming days bringing a
cease and desist letter to oil and gas
CEOs demanding they stop any new oil and
gas projects
now the U.S climate Envoy has backed the
United Arab Emirates decision to appoint
the CEO of a state-run oil company to
preside over the upcoming U.N climate
negotiations in Dubai or John Kerry said
Sultan our Jabba's appointment was a
terrific Choice sightseeing his work on
renewable energy projects
I think that Dr Sultan al-jabbar is a
terrific choice because he is the head
of the company
that company knows it needs to
transition he knows and the leadership
of the UAE is committed to transitioning
and in fact the UA is one of the largest
investors in renewable energy
and if you listen to the speech he gave
yesterday the Atlanta Council he made it
absolutely clear we're not moving fast
enough we have to reduce emissions we
have to begin to accelerate this
transition significantly so I have great
confidence that the right issues are
going to be on the table
most 4 000 baby seals have been spotted
along a Five Mile Stretch of coast in
Norfolk this winter a record number it
demonstrates conditions are good enough
to support a healthy Colony PT Ansel
chairman of friends of horsey seals
which works to protect the animals from
disturbance said the population boom
when it's down to the fish as currently
the North Sea is providing enough fish
for thousands of seals
beavers are set to be reintroduced into
an enclosure in Hampshire marking the
first time in 400 years that they've
lived in the country in Southern England
now a pair of the semi-aquatic mammals
will be released to euhurst park estate
which is being restored for nature and
sustainable food production
now storms in California continued over
the weekend bringing renewed fears of
flooding and mudslides after weeks of
heavy rainfall more than 19 people have
died and flood watches remain in place
for around 8 million people now the
latest storm is expected to bring up to
three feet of snow in Sierra Nevada and
back-to-back atmospheric Rivers have
been blamed for huge floods but what
exactly are they well I'm joined Now by
The Royal meteorological society's chief
executive Professor Liz Bentley Liz
thanks so much for joining us this
afternoon
good afternoon
um so just let us know what are these
atmospheric rivers and why do they in
some cases cause so much trouble
yeah so these are narrow bounds of uh
areas high up in the atmosphere that
hold more water vapor more moisture in
the atmosphere they're effectively
rivers in the sky and because there's
more moisture there more water vapor it
means that when they reach land and they
form a cloud we find that there's extra
amounts of rainfall that fall from these
atmospheric Rivers the normal weather
systems so it's a continuous feed a
conveyor belt I guess of moisture coming
right uh transported long distances
they're very large scale features that
you can see from space satellites can
pick them up particularly those
satellites that just look at water vapor
themselves and uh Liz as the climate
intensifies and heats up can we expect
then these atmospheric rivers to become
more dangerous
yeah so as our climate warms we know
that the atmosphere can hold more
moisture so a one degree warming in
global average temperatures leads to
about a seven percent increase in the
amount of moisture that it can hold so
we expect these atmospheric rivers to be
able to hold more moisture in a warmer
atmosphere than they would normally do
prior to human induced climate change so
they're going to become more active
there's more moisture there therefore
we're going to see heavier rainfall
events and that's been played out
obviously across California at the
moment with the extreme rainfall that
we're seeing so you know it really very
much is a signature of what our climate
is starting to look like and we'll
continue to look like going forward in
time let's talk to me about adaptation
in this area for a moment because I know
that forecasting of these atmospheric
Rivers they can be what about five to
seven days in advance
yeah they're very large scale systems so
they our computer models that look at
forecasts a few days or a few weeks
ahead pick these systems up quite nicely
and then you have the local detail of
where that rain is going to fall or snow
in the case of of uh the rain that's
falling over the higher ground it fall
falls in the form of snow
um and so we can predict these things
well in advance and put warnings in
place so part of I guess the the
adaptation is to get early warnings out
we can't stop the rain from falling but
we can warn people to be able to to you
know take precautions during these heavy
rainfall events other adaptation things
we really need to look at how we uh yeah
our Urban Development so the materials
we use within towns and cities uh aren't
poor of us they don't allow that
moisture that rainfall to soak into the
ground it just forms more localized
flooding so we'll need to look at how we
adapt in towns and cities but also
across rural areas we need to change our
agricultural practices so that we we
allow the soil able to become more
adaptable to hold on to that moisture we
don't take down forests for example
because the the trees themselves can
hold the moisture and we support areas
of wetlands and peatlands which again
access sponge to to store that moisture
so we there's things we can definitely
do with our kind of land use our Urban
Development to to help to adapt to the
the extreme rainfall that we're already
seeing playing out across across parts
of the world and let's just briefly if
we look closer to home you will know
more than anyone you know we've got
forecast a lot of rain previously and
coming up in the next few days can we
expect here in the UK to experience more
of these types of rivers
um closer to home
yeah we have experienced atmospheric
rivers in the UK they come all the way
from the tropical regions like the
Azores and it pumps all that moisture up
to the UK and then it falls in the form
of rain we have weather systems as well
that coming off the Atlantic deep areas
of low so we kind of get hit by by both
effects I guess the atmospheric Rivers
but also our weather weather systems
developing off the Atlantic and again
we're looking really to when the next
weather systems are going to come in
because the ground's already saturated
and any extra rainfalling on it will
lead to further flooding okay Liz
Bentley really interesting to talk to
you thanks for your time on the daily
climate show today
well that's all from us today but don't
worry we're back tomorrow with a whole
lot more see you soon bye